the man who'll be in Wisconsin calling
Maryland in Wisconsin along with Joe
Davis and Bruce Feldman on the sidelines
he is Brady Quinn how are you Brady I'm
doing well rich always a pleasure beyond
thanks for having me right back at you
let's get right into it let's get into
this big game your alma mater against
USC what is it like around campus in
Notre Dame in the locker room when it's
USC week what is that like well I think
there's USC week where you know neither
team is maybe in contention and there's
USC weeks where one of them is and then
there's USC week when both are and
that's what we have this week and I got
to tell you rich there's a buzz on
campus I mean there's it's unlike
anything you've ever felt and you go
back to the 2005 matchup we had in South
Bend
the the bush push quote-unquote game and
you will and you could tell on Tuesday
people started showing up on campus
people are already waiting outside of
practice for us to sign autographs and
talk to us I mean it was that early in
the week where you could steal the hype
that the pep rallies that the dorms
would put on on the quads even the pep
rally before the game it was so big rich
they had to move it inside the stadium
there was only 40,000 people the entire
half the stadium was filled bottom the
top on one half that side just for the
pep rally it was an entirely different
feeling unlike anything yeah I didn't
really experienced that her name up to
that point in my career so there's
definitely something special about this
rivalry about this matchup well if you
will is a phrase it's a way that you can
kind of couch the statement that you're
making there's no question Reggie pushed
Matt Leinart
Brady there's no question he shoved him
into that endzone no it's not but
there's a couple rules of thought there
yes 1 USC you're kind of accustomed to
seeing them cheat a little bit know that
you're talking to a Michigan guy where
you know they lost a Rose ball to USC
where someone did not even have the
football going over the goal line for a
touchdown that happened they don't have
a problem with it right but I think I
always look at that play now and I've
told I told Matt thaiss I would have
hoped Darius Walker would have pushed me
into if it came down to that because
that's what you you think in that
situation as a competitor you do all you
can to win even if it may be crosses a
line and and today that plays legal now
so even though it was illegal back then
you can now push a player into the end
zone now so it's not as if we can have
as big of a gripe even though it was
illegal back then and and I can see
exactly what Madeline and Reggie Bush
we're trying to do they're trying to
hold on to that win streak they're
trying to hold on to everything that
they had built up to at that point their
careers at USC and in terms of the
current iteration of these teams
how good is Notre Dame in your
estimation Brady I think they're they're
really really good and I think it really
goes back to the base of football that's
winning at the line of scrimmage
that to me is what I've seen that
opportunity to call a Michigan State
gave us Iowa this year so I got to break
down a lot of that Notre Dame versus
Michigan State game and one of the
things that really popped on film to me
was the domination of the offensive
lines for Notre Dame up front from
center to their left tackle that is an
NFL offensive line playing on Saturdays
that's how good you know McGlinchey and
Nelson must are now that's how good
those guys are up front and how dominant
they can be on the defensive line you
start to see more push against a
Michigan State team which I think you'd
admit rich it's pretty decent it's
pretty good and Notre Dame looks like
the much more talented much more
physical team in that matchup when I was
breaking it down on film so that's the
first thing that really stands out to me
is unless you want to talk about
up-tempo offenses and spread offenses
all that they win the battle in the
trenches and that's what they're gonna
have to do versus USC this weekend Brady
Quinn of Fox Sports joining us here in
the DirecTV 4k
college football game of the week and
yes you know scoreboard is the
scoreboard and Michigan State was a
better team that day against Michigan
that said I would say that Michigan is
struggling with a backup quarterback in
oh corn that you personally eyeballed
come on in that field and Purdue in the
second half of the game and move the
offense in a way that Wilton Speight
wasn't able to do before then but now
where there's a couple of games under
oak horns belt
it's just have been a flat-out struggle
on offense and now here comes Penn State
this weekend which has been on tilt
like a pinball machine all season long
how do you see Michigan being able to go
point four point in this game Brady
that's the tough part riches is I don't
know if they can right now the way their
offense is played and and you mentioned
the game we were calling Michigan versus
Purdue when John oh corn came in he
really sports the offense and I kind of
had high hopes for him being able to
continue to replicate that in the
ensuing weeks and and I think the hard
thing is as a quarterback you know you
feel two different ways when you're a
backup and you come into a game where
you really didn't have any reps any
practice you don't feel as much pressure
because you weren't prepared for the
moments you just go out there and you do
the best you can and and sometimes you
know that's feeling that of a carefree
play if you will sometimes plays your
benefit and then you look at the past
couple weeks when you are the guy
everyone's looking at you everyone's
asking you about certain plays what's
happening what you like what you don't
like you start to feel that pressure and
some guys don't internalize that as well
as others and some actually struggle
being in that position more so than
others and I think that's been the issue
you know watching John O corn over the
past few weeks compared to what I saw
with them kind of coming off the bench
on to replace Speights so that's maybe
the toughest part is if this offense can
get in gear versus a really really good
Penn State team that you know obviously
runs the football well with say Quan
Barclay but it's also I mean it's the
passing game how they get him touches it
straight McQuoid some the you know
downfield throwing game but even the
short intermediate passes that I think
he's improved from last year to this
year with so and it's gonna be tough and
look Penn State's coming off a bye so
they got even more time to prepare as
well that doesn't bode well commission
well Michigan does have that defense
that Penn State has not seen a defense
like the one that they're gonna be
seeing out there on the field on
Saturday give me the recipe for for a
surprise on behalf of Michigan please
Brady well the way to ask a Notre Dame
guy this very question please don't
worry I think the biggest thing is gonna
be try to find a way to stop say Quan
Barclay and we're running the football
and it sounds simple that it is because
tres books always a part of that but if
you can find a way of making Penn State
one-dimensional
on defense if you're Michigan
I mean that to me gives you the greatest
opportunity for success because with
your offense struggling the way it has
you've got to play the field position
battle you got to put them behind the
sticks on first and second down so so
really if you're Michigan to me you got
to play tight man-to-man coverage the
entire time you can't afford to play off
coverage and give tres McSorely any easy
throws on first and second down to allow
them to be in more in third management
where they keep the entire PlayBook in
you can't afford to do that so there
have to play tight they're going to play
a lot you utilize a decent mount of
pressure at times a mixed mix that and
throughout the course of the game to
really force Penn State to be a little
bit you know on their heels and not
allow them to have the opportunity to
just continue to matriculate the ball
down the field like we see them have or
have big plays I think that's the
toughest part is you know I'm not sure
how many guys in Michigan can ultimately
really match up a stake on Berkeley in
coverage if you do go man-to-man
coverage that's something that Penn
State likes to do but but you know
that's the position you have to be and I
think up against this team because of
mcsally's ability to run the football
now fishing he's been throwing this
football and maybe just if he comes out
of the backfield rashon Gary just gives
him a pop trying to come out of that
backfield rotten knock him over out or
something like that if that's possible
but unless they split him out wide then
it's a whole different ball of wax
obviously you can butch the back after
they call it a lot of times yeah I try
to give a shot on him but again you got
to still go to put pressure on McSorley
I think now feel good if you just let it
sit back there and build a dissect you
know their defense eventually someone's
gonna get open so that's gonna be the
biggest issue it's gonna be a fun
matchup offense defense like that
Sam Donald or say Quon Berkeley who's a
better pro prospect Brady and I would
say the way this year is gone right now
it's a say Quon Barkley I'm not even
being really sure if it's that close you
know after last season I might have said
Sam Donnell after watching what he was
able to do but you know this year that I
mean look the biggest thing I once I
smelled an NFL game is the turnover
margin turnover battle and you know Sam
Donald's fumbled the football throw too
many interceptions this season and it
kind of makes you question maybe a
little bit of the decision-making how he
still has the ability to just you know
make throws that you don't see happen
very often in the college level
especially in big moments but say come
on Berkeley right now looks like
a guy who is gonna transition very
easily to the NFL level
can you believe Brady Quinn last one for
you that darn 'old or rosin or allen or
you know perhaps Baker may feel that the
Browns are still maybe in the they're
definitely in the business of looking
for somebody like that you are one of
the 28 different starting quarterbacks
for that organization since they came
back into being it's really unbelievable
I'm never surprised by it though only
because you know again they've
implemented the definition of insanity
in the way they've handled things and it
starts at the top with Jimmy Haslam the
way you continue it keeps firing coaches
after two years and firing general
managers after two years no one's ever
there long enough to give you any sort
of sense of offended I think they're
doing is working but the problem is you
can't even build a foundation of a house
and you keep knocking it over after
every time you get started and you have
someone come in that wants to change the
way they're going to draw the plans for
the house and change you know where they
want to put the garage or they'll put
the master better maybe that's what
you're talking about
you're talking about a team that every
single time they try to lay a foundation
instead of foundation start to build
something someone's coming back in and
demolishing it knocking it back down
it's typically been Jimmy Haslam their
ownership but there's much talk about
the quarterback position I don't care if
it's Carson Wentz or whoever else want
to talk about they passed on at the
quarterback position this team isn't
playing well enough out around them to
give them help and that's one of the
biggest issues and I was behind to 22
you know they're always mentioned the
quarterback position and the guys they
passed on
well why just limit it to that why nots
talking about start talking about wide
receivers they passed on or other
linemen or other defensive players
they've passed on I mean you're just
you're just only using one position I
mean clearly there's been a bunch of
mistakes as far as how things have
worked out for Cleveland but
unfortunately until they actually have
some continuity it they're not gonna
find whoever that quarterback is because
he's gonna get the crap kicked out of
them with the ability to protect them or
he's not gonna have a lot of success
because like right now they don't have a
playmakers and the outside help him out
well they do seem to have continuity
here in all honesty with Shashi brown
and deep deep Podesta in the front
office with Hugh Jackson you know and
but somebody if somebody oh I've been
there but it's only Hugh Jackman's going
into a second year and then Paul
DePodesta
his second year so somebody there's
looked at Carson Wentz one of those
three names I just said looked at Carson
Wentz and said we don't want him
somebody said that and now he's five and
one it's unbelievable Brady but look at
the Eagles team rich I mean for us to
sit there and say what they have built
out around him is is equivalent to what
the Browns have honey you're nuts
they've got one of the best offensive
lines especially Lane Johnson's in there
that there's the NFL they've got a bunch
of different playmakers now that we're
singing at five and one scene they
invested in doing the offseason and it's
really helped him improve and they've
got a defense look at Jim Schwartz the
job they've done with the defense to get
him the football give them better fuel
position and there's a lot of those
things are playing you know to his favor
he's a great player I don't know who
made that evaluation I was really high
on him I'm not sure you know how they
they came to that conclusion everyone's
got their different formulas and
everyone's got their different way of
viewing things but the bottom line is
football the greatest team sport they
still haven't figured out how to build
out around it so whoever's playing
quarterback they can at least help them
out I mean you can't sell me that the
Baltimore Ravens when they want a Super
Bowl at Trent Dilfer as the quarterback
you know all of a sudden had the best
often so they dominate defense but the
problem is we all keep going back to
that quarterback position actually
acting like that's what when you Super
Bowls every year majority of time yes
but not every year you can have a really
good team too that helps out that
quarterback position
well while Michigan plays Penn State
this week and then Penn State plays Ohio
State this week Wisconsin's just gonna
kick back and watch them all try and
kick the crap out of each other they
take on Maryland this weekend with you
in the booth with Joe Davis and Bruce
Feldman look forward to that game Bri
thanks for calling I'm looking forward
to it as well
thanks too much for me already you bet
that's Brady Quinn in the DirecTV 4k
college football report the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy